[Applause]
he was out making every second count
chasing every last vote because Benjamin
Netanyahu needs them maybe one of the
great political survivors of our time
but the odds are stacking up against him
he's fighting for his political life but
perhaps also his freedom beset with
corruption scandals and indictments
hanging over he's battling with this
ex-general benny ganz head of the blue
and white party with a spotless military
record and reputation for honesty but
after election six months ago this was
Netanyahu's biggest problem and still is
bouncer turned politician a lie turn
rival Avigdor Lieberman he's ruled out
joining a Netanyahu coalition if the
ultra-orthodox are in it to the
religious writer turning out their
voters but on their own they're not
enough to hand Netanyahu the coalition
he needs to govern and on the other side
Arab Israelis may for the first time
support Jewish Israeli parties to topple
Netanyahu to win over more voters on the
right Benjamin Netanyahu is promising
them this 1/3 of the occupied West Bank
on the Jordanian border will be annexed
he says to the horror of allies
including Britain saying that what all
but kill off hopes of a Palestinian
state and listen Yahoo also stands
accused of scare mongering calling an
emergency party meeting to deal with a
threat of Arabs coming out to vote it is
beginning to look just a little bit
desperate since the mid-90s Israelis
have put their faith more often than not
in Benjamin Netanyahu putting aside
allegations of corruption and political
wheeler dealing and seeing him most of
all as the best bet to keep them safe
but after that failure to build a
coalition in the election six months ago
his luck has started to look like it's
running out the great political operator
may have more lives left enough deals up
his sleeve just to build a coalition and
win a record fifth term in office or
perhaps after so many years dominating
the region's politics it may soon be
time to bow
is the Netanyahu era drawing to a close
Dominic Waghorn Sky News in Jerusalem